saul khan is here he's the founder of
khanacademy.org he provides 10-minute
tutorials on the web on everything from
math to science to finance the harvard
mba and former hedge fund manager has
become an online teaching sensation his
videos have been viewed more than 50
million times worldwide they have been
translated to more than seven different
languages here is a look
so the hypotenuse is now going to be
five this animals fossils are only found
in this area of south america a nice
clean band here and this part of africa
we could integrate over the surface and
the notation usually is a capital sigma
national assembly they create the
committee of public safety which sounds
like a very nice committee some cells
have a membrane around the dna this is
called a nucleus notice this is an
aldehyde and it's an alcohol start
differentiating into effector and memory
cells a galaxy hey there's another
galaxy and for dollars is there 30
million plus the 20 million dollars from
the american manufacturer if these
things end up being worth
30 cents on the dollar let's say that
you know we go to some future state and
these really are worth only 30 cents
the most that the private investor loses
in this situation is his seven dollars
if this does not blow your mind
then you have no emotion
i am pleased to have falcon at this
table for the first time welcome thanks
for having me so what am i just looking
at i'm looking at someone who's
interested in everything and has a
passion to tell others i i i think so
yeah that's what i've turned into
what have you turned into
yeah i've turned into um someone i guess
from my point of view who gets to you
know i started off with the math and the
physics and and the science and the
economic stuff that i knew
fairly well from my background uh but
but now i've turned into someone who
gets to learn pretty much anything and
and distill it down and and teach it
yeah you're learning new things
assimilating them distilling them and
then teaching them yeah so give me the
background
that you have
well i was uh as you mentioned
five six years ago i was an analyst at a
hedge fund before that my background was
in software then i went to business
school you know did the hedge fund thing
i started in boston and while i was in
boston i had family visiting me from new
orleans this was right after my wedding
this was in 2004
and uh what my cousin nadia i remember
we're waiting for the fireworks over the
charles river and we were just killing
time and i started giving these brain
teasers the type of brain teacher you'd
give it like a software interview for
like you know 25 year old engineering
and you know most people just disengage
like i don't want to
deal with that i don't want to think
right now but not here's a 12 year old
she was like don't tell me the answer i
need to figure it out okay can they see
each other and all these type of things
about the brain teaser and i was pretty
impressed and um
and and you know i started telling her
and her mother hey you should think
about becoming an engineer or whatever
and the next morning her mom nasrathanti
told me
thanks for believing in navia but she's
actually being tracked into a slower
math class like the non-advanced track
and i said that's impossible the stuff
she was doing yesterday is way beyond
her she's clearly a bright girl and uh
she's like no i think she did bad on a
placement exam and so when nadia woke up
i said what's going on and uh she said
no i you know i apparently she had
bombed units converting you know gallons
to quartz and i was like nah yeah you
know i can understand how that can be
confusing but the stuff you're doing
last night was way deeper and way harder
than than units and if you're willing to
work with me when you go back to new
orleans and i'll stay here in boston
i think we can get you past whatever
hurdles you have and she agreed and they
went back to new orleans and every day
after work i would come home and we'd
get on the speaker phone for about half
an hour an hour and i'd start working
with her and uh it worked out two three
months she she got up to speed went
ahead of the curve then i started
tutoring her brothers other family
members and then
you fast forward to 2006 so it's about
you know 18 months have gone by and i
was venting to a buddy i was like you
know this is a lot of fun i'm having and
by this time i had moved out to
california and i was like this is a lot
of fun it's really satisfying but you
know the first time you give a lecture
on least common multiples it's kind of
fun the second time is still fun a
little more polished the third time it
starts to get a little bit tiring just
to do
and and he said
do it one time do it one time why don't
you put it on youtube
and i said no youtube's for dogs on
skateboards it's not it's not for
serious learning
and uh
i i you know once i got over the fact
that it wasn't my idea i decided to give
it a shot and uh i put it up there and
and uh which one did you put up there it
was either least common multiple or
greatest common divisor i forget i think
i did them on the same day that first
day and and the cool thing about youtube
is you can sort by upload time so that
first video you'd shown that was
literally that was one of the early
videos i kind of cringed i was like oh
that's when i wasn't using the fancy hd
stuff but yeah it was on one of those
topics and the reaction
you know what that about 20 or 30 up
there
my cousin's initial reaction and i i
joke about this but it's true is that
they preferred me on on youtube than in
person
you know i i i'll take that for what
it's worth and um but but it made sense
you need not come to the next family
gathering
just yeah there wasn't uh yeah sal could
be annoying sometimes something so and
then when did it become khan academy uh
if you fast forward
it it soon became clear like maybe in
six months even from the beginning
random people started watching it but
then fast forward six months i probably
had 50 or 100 videos and i started
getting these random letters from people
on just on youtube just and if you look
on youtube people aren't always that
civil on youtube in terms of what they
write but for the most part everyone's
writing hey this thanks a bunch this
helped me and then some people would
write i was going to flunk calculus
until i got this video or i was going to
drop out of you know i wasn't going to
become an engineer because i couldn't
handle the course load until i saw that
video on vectors or whatever it might be
and so uh
it started to dawn on me that this could
be more than a hobby although it's data
hobby right then and uh
you fast i think the first time khan
academy came about i think was either
um i decided to to set up my own domain
name and and so i have another way of
viewing the videos and i also started
working on the software for my cousin so
i could give them problems
exercise and i put it all on on that
site and i was working for a hedge fund
called wool capital and my my boss was
dan wool and i said well i'm sal khan so
i call it khan academy
and so what are your dreams what do you
want it to be
you know if i um and i used to be kind
of quiet about this dream because it
seemed kind of like a crazy thing maybe
you know even even last year would have
seemed crazy for me to say what i'm
about to say but
now
i think there's a potential for
you know right now online learning no
one takes it they take it seriously they
think it has value but they don't the
online learning is here and your
prestigious universities are over here
they're not in the same conversation
i'm hoping khan academy can turn into an
institution
that i don't want to say rivals but it's
talked in the same conversation as some
of these things that have been around
the places where you can learn
in the places where you can learn you
know at a very high level so you can
start at arithmetic but you can go deep
and it's a real learning experience it's
not something superficial so how many
people work for you now we have eight
people
we just have it we had six if you'd
asked last week and so eventually you'll
give diplomas
that that's an open question you know
and this is if you focus just on k
through 12 and and our video content
goes well beyond k-12 but just on k-12
right now what really matters is some of
these standardized tests the sats the ap
tests and um you know high school
diplomas the kids are getting into
harvard based on just being being
homeschooled right now and so
we see our our real niche right now on
the learning side
standard education is really learning
and credentialing and we're going to
tackle the learning as well as we can
and in the future we'll see what what we
can do on the credentials i mean you've
got a remarkable group of people who
believe what you're doing people from
google bill gates and a lot of others
you know have cited you for what you
have done and what you are doing is
there any pushback from what you have
accomplished does anybody say
yes but
they're you know i i they're they're
my so my sense of the pushback is
sometimes these articles get written
where the the article itself is fairly
balanced and reasonable but they'll
title it like will khan academy demolish
traditional education or where was this
one oh i don't know i i'm exactly okay i
mean there was one that recently came
out would it invert that it flip the
classroom or turn education upside down
or something like that so there's these
headlines that are very
attention-grabbing right and so i think
when someone reads that they've become
cynical about these you know these these
panacea solutions to a big problem and
and so they might say oh no there's no
way that something like this could solve
all of our problems but for the most
part i think when people understand what
they're doing it's uh
we haven't gotten a lot of resistance
and who are the people who are watching
it's you know and that's the surprising
thing who's watching is when i started
off it was for my cousins and i kind of
just made them for
my cousins were they wanted to learn i
was there as kind of their big brother
type figure and so i was motivating them
and when i
still when i make the videos i'm kind of
like well if i wanted to learn the
subject what would i want how would i
want it to be explained and it was
i thought that it would appeal to a
certain subset of people you know people
who are people who like to watch you
know the discovery channel and charlie
rose and
and all the rest
but uh
what's and so i'm really focused on the
intuition and the going deep and showing
how it connects and all of these things
that sometimes get lost in textbooks in
some classes
but the surprising thing is i get
letters from
that that group of people but i do get
letters from parents of students with
learning disabilities uh uh kids who are
otherwise disengaged from
math class or from school generally and
then over here they all of a sudden
discover love so that is the most
important question about that come out
of this conversation between the two of
us what is it you know what is it you do
that somehow
makes learning
more
attractive more interesting
more satisfying and more productive you
know i i don't know that i definitely
have the answer i i have guesses
yeah yeah i think it's um
you know i started off making it for my
cousins and so
i kind of didn't care and i was kind of
like this liberated person if someone
had told me in 2004 i'm going to give
you a couple million dollars produce
something that's gonna reach millions of
people and bill gates is gonna watch it
and all the rest i probably would have
produced something different i probably
would have gotten fancy lighting and put
some makeup on and got some computer
graphics and probably produced a lot of
the education material that's already
out there these computer graphics the
next stage of photosynthesis is
you know and um but i think the reality
is is that's what we all assume as good
content but when someone watches that
it's so dehumanizing it's you kind of
check out you're like that's not talking
to me and and so when i made it it was
literally just me in a room people could
tell some dude he's not getting paid
he's making it for his cousins and so
they can tell there's a human element to
it they can tell that you know a lot of
times when people are trying to get
people engaged into math they try to
distract them they'll do like a rap song
or they'll play all this music and and i
think people find that patronizing
they're like look don't distract me if
math is good it should be able to stand
up on its own that's exactly what i
believe about this show the same thing
it's a black room yes
just a conversation between interesting
people yeah no and that's all it is and
that's what people want they don't want
a lot of no you're not insulting people
if you have bells and whistles this
meaning that you're it's not worth
watching yeah yeah yeah let me see
saulcon is a very interesting person if
you don't know about him you'll learn a
whole lot here and and this kind of
conversation will penetrate that veil of
of
complexity yeah yeah and give you a
channel to access complexity i know i
wholeheartedly agree i mean maybe i was
subconsciously no you weren't but it is
the same idea when i hear you say it i
realize that's exactly what we approach
that's our mindset as well so what's the
hardest thing about this
um
you know 24 hours in a day 24 hours in a
day i think now the hardest thing is i
really want me to be all about
continuing to make videos i want most of
my day um kind of
the learning and the producing but what
but
and this is another interesting thing
about khan academy because i put these
videos out there and people watch them
and
i'm kind of associated with them and i i
can use that as a
as a platform to to i guess engage in
the discussion
how you know however you want to view it
but uh i still think my biggest role and
and probably the highest leverage for my
time are those videos and even though
those videos you know that video on on
online integrals in the first week might
only be watched by a few hundred people
i think over the next hundred years
that'll be a
that'll be a big impact do anybody do
people come to you all the time and say
this we can monetize this
they they they they used to so i don't
know about two or three years ago when
khan academy had gotten to kind of
people started to know about it um but i
still had my day job at the hedge fund i
started a couple of vcs approached hey
we could do a double bottom line hybrid
model
freemium or whatever you know all these
things and and actually i got to meeting
two with one of them and uh meeting one
was a lot of fun because they're like
hey we can you can make a salary to do
this and if it all works out you're
going to be rich and all of that but
then meeting two is like so let's focus
on this market because we can monetize
this i was like no but i feel like doing
civil war videos like why should i do
you know and uh uh
and so meeting two yeah so i said no and
i can't because it was too much fun to
give up the fun part of it regardless of
the upside and and so uh
yeah so when you f so so that's actually
became clear when
even though i didn't know what a
non-profit kind of would entail to start
and how do you raise money for anything
that's where it became clear that no i
want it to be a i was like you know what
are all these universes oh they're not
for profits i want to be a
not-for-profit too so that's what you've
become that's what we've become and so
you get a lot of money from people like
gates or john dora or vandoorne people
like that who believe in what you do and
say
yeah yeah and i you know ann and john
were the first literally you know i'd
quit my job in 2009 and
you know the savings started to go like
this
and it was it was ann in particular who
who really stepped up and and you know
allowed me to get us the first salary
and then and then google and bill gates
and everyone else start to get involved
in
take a tangent from you for a second
what's what's wrong with the way we
teach
um
i i think it's more than the way we
teach i think it's a systemic thing of
of how the school is structured is that
you know
right now you have you know you and i
were sitting in algebra class or a
pre-algebra class and they're going over
negative numbers and uh you know maybe
you get a 95 on the exam you get you
feel good about yourself you get an a
stamped on your forehead whatever i
listen i get a 70 it's a c or a d um
and so so there's an assessment and it
does identify that i have big weaknesses
you have even some weaknesses you had a
95 so there's still five percent you
didn't know and negative numbers is a
core thing you need to know that really
well
but despite that the whole class then
moves to the next concept and builds on
they assume that everyone had mastery
when they've just shown that no one does
and so you keep marching everyone down
that path and people just keep having
gaps in their knowledge and what you
have is when you get to and we've all
seen this with ourselves family members
everyone hits a certain math class or
certain science class where they hit a
wall where all of a sudden that a
student or that b student just starts
flunking they just can't and they have
good teachers they're trying to study
and it's just they're they're hitting
their head against the wall it's because
they have all of these gaps and once
you're in algebra class there's no way
to identify the gap in fourth grade or
identify the gap in pre-algebra or once
you're in calculus there's no way to
identify that algebra gap and i think
that that's the problem no matter how
good a teacher you have you have just
these these a weak foundation they said
fortune august 24th his low-tech
conversational tutorials khan's face
never appears and viewers see only his
unadorned step-by-step doodles and
diagrams on an electronic blackboard
more than merely another example of
viral media distributed inedible clause
to the universe khan academy holds a
promise of virtual school and
educational transformation that
de-emphasizes classrooms campus and
administrative infrastructure and even
brand name instructors quick free and
easy to understand
khan has his skeptics in the education
business they don't doubt he means well
and is helping students but they
question the broad impact of any
tutorial that doesn't test performance
or allow student teacher discussion
is that a point
it's a point
it is a point you know and everybody's
that last point is that that's exactly
why you know we have the videos and i
keep making videos but then as soon as
we got funding that that little simple
software that i started building for my
cousins to to measure what what they
knew and what they didn't know that's
why we started building it into this
exercise platform and and so i think
over time the videos will always be a
big part of khan academy but this
exercise piece where students start one
plus one it keeps generating problems
for them until they can get tender until
they master a concept and only then move
on to the next concept that's going to
become a bigger and bigger piece of it
so to rebut that no we are doing the the
assessment and the feedback do you see
it as supplementary to the process of
education or a main line in the process
of education
our goal
and you know we view ourselves as in the
beginning of this process you know i've
been at it for five years but as an
organization we've only been at it for
six or seven months but our goal is is
that with khan academy alone
if there's a student in calcutta you
know internet they need an internet
connection so that's that's a gating
factor but if they're there they can get
a pretty solid grounding in a lot of
different subject areas especially ones
that are meaningful to them that they
can use to progress but
we think it can also be the operating
system of what happens in a classroom to
really liberate
what happens inside of a classroom
um
how many of them do you do yourself i've
i produced all the videos what i thought
yeah i'm the faculty
faculty our meetings are very
non-bureaucratic and so let's assume
you're interested in napoleon and the
french revolution
what do you do
how do you prepare
how do you what's the process of going
from i'm curious about napoleon to this
is what i have to teach you this is your
access to understand this moment in
history yeah you know and so once again
i approach it from
what my brain would like to see like
what was the ideal and for me
in history in particular
and and i don't feel like i got this in
the history books and even now when i
prepare i'm not getting it from the
history books on my shelf it's like i
like to see a scaffold i like to see a
map i like to you know what is the holy
roman empire like where what is that now
like an empire
what are these things you know people
can just keep referring to them but if i
can't i couldn't so i i like to so so
what i do is for history i immerse
myself in as much as possible i usually
read wikipedia entry first just to get
the just to get the scaffold oh yeah
yeah yeah no i go for the scaffold get
the scaffold just as a learning
experience just as i want to see where
it fits exactly see the geography of the
place exactly and what does it look like
exactly and the beauty now also
wikipedia if i find cool maps along the
way i copy and paste you know i make
sure they're in the public domain i copy
and paste stick it on my uh my little
blackboard art program and uh sometimes
i'll draw out a timeline just to make
sure i get the
the years right but the main thing i do
whether it's history or chemistry or
anything is
get the scaffold and then really immerse
myself for
however long it takes and then make sure
that i can make intuitive connections
between everything that happens and you
know and this is what's that an
intuitive connection
understand
why something you know if i'm if i'm
doing it on the neuron why
you know a a biology book will tell you
okay the signal goes across because
there's a myelin sheath and i'm like
yeah but how does have putting a little
tissue around a neuron how does it make
the signal go faster right and no
biology book will tell you that answer
and i'd kind of pondered a little bit
and then i was like well it's kind of
like a fiber optic system and you can
one's kind of a
amplifying the signal but if you amplify
too and then i'd call up some buddies
who are either biologists or or or
or communications engineers or whatever
i was like does this make sense like no
i think you're right and so it's a big
deal for me to
if i'm doing biology why is the myelin
sheath make the signal go faster if it's
history wait why did this guy why did
this artillery captain all of a sudden
come to power like like weren't there
other people around like these obvious
questions
are important for for for me to answer
yeah and what's really cool is sometimes
you call a buddy and you're like i know
you're gonna think i'm stupid when i ask
you this and you're probably gonna think
i have no business making a video on
this considering i'm asking this
question but you know why does the
sarcoplasmic reticulum release these
ions when this happens and they're like
you know what we don't know
and i was like why didn't the book tell
me that like it's like it would have
been yeah everyone's like what are the
people what do your former colleagues at
the hedge fund say
they're they're super happy about it i
mean you know
my last boss told me if i knew you were
going to do this i wouldn't i wouldn't
have hired you
it's great to find this thing it's great
to find something that you have great
passion for and it involve learning
yourself you know i think i've
subconsciously been inspired by you uh
you know years ago i said charlie rose
got the best job like he's just got to
learn everything and he gets to so i'm
you know i'm doing it in my own way
it's great to meet you thank you very
much oh thank you it's all khan khan
academy.com